great okay clear
background so let's roll up when you're
[Music]
ready
basically for the whole time you've just
got [__] all in your hands and you're
trying to act
very very intimidating but you're also
meant to be coming across a bit nervous
my question is if i'm getting up at the
shop can that camera go with me as i get
a public shot
or is that a problem for you guys say i
do that and i take my jacket off the
back
and go just don't spend it all on
another car
that's cool okay wow i'd love to hear
easy that's great
the way brian's reaction is wouldn't
even cover it wouldn't even cover the
petrol it wouldn't even cut the
at which point we then cut to rory who's
sort of going
yeah yeah he's sort of going i think i
would have won that yeah
that's like a really nice finish to that
scene that he's dropped out and then
we're in
here we are live behind the scenes of
the poker stars
having a lot of fun i went away last
night to get these shoes look at these
shoes
premium you know how much these cost me
a lot it turns out
you won't even see them on camera so
brian's close by the way
he'll be here okay
we've been talking so much [__] about
you and you're finally here all right
so this isn't sorry the hand that you
scripted
is kind of not dramatic what i've
scripted is
it makes it look like you've got lucky
i'll do whatever you
want you're done with that okay adam was
thrilled when he read the script so
how it would have went down anyway i've
already seen you when you're stressing
over football so i've tried to imagine
it's important
this is made before makeup look at all
the imperfections
get a good look i'm about to look
beautiful feels a bit
i thought you'd be more gentle to me
honestly i'm worried if i like this i
might end up wanting to do it all the
time
so i'm getting a bit older now do you do
botox as well by any chance because we
could probably do a little bit of that
get on you're not called anyway but now
you look young
feels like you get married people get
hired
yeah yeah we're just playing poker yeah
what's making money
the other one giving it away and then
making videos so
do you want to see the stairs the stairs
and they're quite nice okay
i'll be right back lawrence he's going
to show me around but i'm just looking
at snacks instead well they thought
is
at one point jerry hollywell sat on
those stairs yeah and posh spice as well
but now it's us she's gonna cut the
cameras and brian can go moving on up in
the world yeah
how would you basically tell us that you
actually are bluffing yeah
i would probably say lads chad [__]
yeah you can say that try and turn over
your your cards and just show them that
give those two jokers
yeah that's chat [__]
[Music]
i'm going to give it all away eventually
you know how many people have that
thought they've actually become homeless
rory
i didn't have them you know when i watch
these
like poker things when i watch them at
home and the girls come out with the
tiffany things and they pull the cash on
the thing
yeah do you walk away with that cash is
that a genuine thing
no so you'll go to the cage you can't
get it in cash but not the cash that's
there right
so let's listen for dan's action yeah
and
um
i feel like it looks weird when adam's
face finally appears overall
you literally don't see him at any point
until like the last two seconds
[Music]
just filming out on the stairs
she's definitely something that has been
tapped
[Music]
yeah if you start with three then work
you up to four five six because this is
a sign of someone who really knows what
they're doing
which is
okay clear backgrounds let's roll up the
market when you're ready
finally the degree comes in handy no
didn't even do scripting during the
degree
do you know what i spent tomorrow
university you know he's ten times
better than me
guys on camera so i went to my
university look at him now choose
feature films
so google what was there nice to meet
you professional finally
you look like [__] lauren
i'm sorry by the way when we do actually
do the live shows and stuff for pogba
i don't think we should be sitting there
and [__] silence like these poker
players
having regular shots like that's just a
podcast really but we wouldn't have them
anywhere you'd have
mentally i'm thinking about wearing
sunglasses think about making that my
thing
[__] off oh you know what i think i need
a thing
i had some glasses in the car can i just
say i love the fact that rory
leaves the house looking like this and
goes i think i need a thing
have you seen him no one else on youtube
looks like rory
but he needs a thing
[Music]
the [__] is it you've got glass
unbelievable
however though i've seen you watching
man united you've got to imagine this is
like man united like
money for you right now like when you're
watching the kickoff you don't you're
not like
saying that again you're going for [__]
sick like you do get a bit more
i would say that in the middle of the
poker hand you don't see people getting
too angry it's usually
this is this is the ours this is this is
the thing yeah like
he's getting impatient yeah he's not
been in the game what the [__] is it you
possibly got
awesome okay
personally i would still do that more
aggressively like that exactly because
if you've been calling him a prick and
everything that
the level of energy you have is it yeah
okay
prick off a [__] sake for fox sake
for [__] sake oh for [__] sake can
we do it without the r
for [__] sake i think that's good
i think you have a lot of options there
you go take all the time you need paul
what are you doing going all in with
seven and three you know what
i'm getting involved i like you anyway
[Music]
okay
have you thought ahead you should have
thought ahead that's what you're gonna
say
yeah i'm lawrence i'm the clever one
he's the big dumb working class one
well i'm afraid not you don't [__] up
just don't spend it on another car yeah
well sure you wouldn't even buy the
petrol
so oh oh king of the castle
oh king of newcastle i'll be buying it
with all this so oh
just so rich
in case the implication wasn't strong
enough i am sorry
your eyes to rory flick your eyes to
brian and then do it all right so i go
and now do i
mm-hmm sometimes i like to imagine you
wearing women's clothes
uh right just a thong or a stocking
suspender
is that to match when you wear the
women's no it's just i just like to
think what we
look like together you know what i mean
yeah i sometimes think if we had sex
changes
what was the reason i said okay right no
no that's where the behind the scenes
gets it all
okay
[Music]
hold up i don't want that yeah cool one
more can you just go oh
i think i have one yeah so don't go hold
up just literally go i think i wonder
i think i'd have won that is there room
for rory to give
a bit of a before his delivery
i don't wonder it's like you you were
made for this
right that's absolutely brilliant
brilliant ryan makes a successful bluff
ryan has a seven nine of spades suited
rory has you two have changed that
king eight of diamonds we get to this
hand on the river
i'm all in you've got to be acting
strong confident stoic
he's going to be like trying to get a
read on you and you're just going to be
a statue
[Music]
so rory just hold your look as long as
you can and then you went to it and then
go back
i heard no man nothing
but you know what i do have bollocks
like a bulldog
three two one balls
super excited about it so you might slam
your chips you might push them in really
quick or whatever
terrible move julie cool
in the montage have we put the line of
rory saying
i'm gonna book a holiday goodbye
dubai i was literally writing this
yesterday imagining you sing it
just like that as well now the setup is
for brian
can become one i think he's leaning on
the table like that you should be like
unbelievable you almost a little bit be
in
disbelief red honey nights when you make
a lot of money and
the mrs is very pleased with you
an alternative would be like uh elon
musk or
jeff bezos jordy b is us yeah i'm jordi
bezos
ryan we're waiting for that last card to
be turned you're not sure
the odds are against you focusing
looking at the card
[__] get it get changed
in here come
i would never have agreed to do it i
would have said get another [__]
booklet
i would have i would have said get
[Music]
congratulations
brian we've taught you rtb i do remember
that
okay guys we're wrapped thank you very
much
i swear well
[Music]
um
you